[Music]
how far can we push technology I
obviously not very far because this is
like the fifth time you've made the
exact same futuristic call of duty game
I'm Gabe ho writer and yes boys androids
it's that time of year again call of
duty Christmas and we're gonna find out
if the new black ops 3 trailer is that
sweet BB gun that I always wanted that
stupid chicken soup for the teenage soul
that my mom thought was a good idea this
is hashtag news a few days ago the team
behind call of duty black ops 3 released
a cinematic teaser trailer that had
everyone thinking that we were finally
gonna get a call of duty game with an
interesting extended campaign story not
just terrorists suck let's kill but then
the actual gameplay trailer dropped and
instead of a potentially brilliant
storyline something that would rival
movies like any of the arcade games they
decided about we just give you more of
this now now that's not to say that
there isn't some cool stuff in there
okay check out this arm cannon machine
gun thing
okay see if the Apple watch did that I
probably did still like it one also
finally catching up with all the cool
kids call of duty will have some new
multiplayer features players will now be
able to pick a specialist class each of
which contains its own set of sweet
weapon here's a clip it's my favorite
class and I played it a lot during the
review session oops yep wronging also
for you parkour fans you can now do some
killer wall running most out of wall
running and jumping because the number
of building wrong game again sorry but
hey at least they're bringing back
zombie mood okay so it looks like there
are some hits and some mrs. which is all
we can really ask for from call of duty
Santa and let's be honest we're just
gonna play a multiplayer okay so be sure
to subscribe to new media rock stars and
leave a comment below on how the trailer
makes you feel down there in the
comments section where the comments go
guys stop it I'm Gabe [ __ ] writer and
with all the killer robots showing up in
games and movies these days it's gonna
be harder to keep my secret you're a
robot no just the world's greatest
dancer why did you suddenly get a robot
Chris shut up
and